madame monsieur bonsoir les jurés de
lyon devait répondre à trois cent
quarante et une question ils ont répondu
oui à 342 ces questions reconnaissant
klaus barbie coupable de dix sept crimes
contre l'humanité ils ont répondu non à
la dernière question pas de
circonstances atténuantes pour l'accusé
il était 12h40 la nuit dernière lorsque
klaus barbie apprenait assidus
présidence erdini qu'il était condamné à
la réclusion à perpétuité
c'était la fin d'un procès de 52 jours
un procès évidemment historique qui sont
concluait sur une journée très lourde
alors sur les dernières heures du procès
voici gérard beaufils et aimé meyer a
lieu je vous demande qu'à vie mardi soir
qu' lui les neuf jurés de la cour
d'assises du rhône et les trois
magistrats professionnels ont suivi les
réquisitions du procureur général
aucune circonstance atténuante n'ont été
retenus
barbie finira donc ses jours en prison
ainsi en a décidé hier soir le jury
populaire
après six heures et demie de délibéré
je trouve que on vient de rendre la
justice mais que barbie a bien mérité sa
condamnation à perpétuité
j'ai beaucoup d'amertume parce qu'il
nous a fallu attendre quarante deux ans
pour que cette justice soit rendue en
même temps et soulagement oui parce que
j'ai vu dans la sambre madame hélène
baumert faute maman de 83 ans passés qui
a perdu des enfants à izieu
je pense que maintenant elle fait sans
aller tranquille je crois que la qualité
des témoins directs les victimes
directes a été tel que si on me permet
de dire lorsqu on montrera le film les
des dépositions et bien je crois que je
crois que ce sera quelque chose peut
être supérieure à chaud
un noeud soirée mouvementée sur les
marches du palais de justice de lyon
après le verdict l'avocat de klaus
barbie quittent les lieux sous les
sifflets et les la dgi de la soul
quelques manifestants quand même un
moment de s'en prendre à lui le dernier
épisode
inutile de ce procès que l'histoire
retiendra comme exemplaire 37 audience
190 heures de débat à des grands et des
petits moments ce qu'ils verront
effectivement la bande vidéo tournée par
ce que l'on appelait les caméras de
l'histoire cela évalueront précisément
le poids de ce procès dans l'histoire
contemporaine